[Music]
- like Posie I remember you when you
guys are there and we did so many
interviews and it was the big press
machine we did a lot of things to
promote the show we first met all the
friends in 1994 just a few months after
they started working together and from
the very start we could tell this brew
was tight we were even there when the
cast was having fun
off the set they're proud of me from
movie premieres to photoshoots yep
that's 13 year old Jessica Biel before 7
heaven we were even Joey which brings us
to this question could there ever be a
reboot
well we did say to each other was if we
ever did reunite let's do it on
Entertainment Tonight
that was the goal for 16 years we've
been asking you about a friend's
rebooted now you said maybe you no no
was getting me nowhere maybe was getting
me nowhere so I don't know I thought I'd
try yes see what happened so what - show
creators Marta Kauffman and David Crane
have to say about it
we've got it right why mess with it it's
a show about the time in your life and
your friends or your family so the show
is no longer viable in this new world
well one thing we know for sure this
cast is still real-life friends goals
for us it's like no time has elapsed
you know you put six people in a
building with no windows for ten years
all day every day and then let them out
they're gonna drift apart but then when
they get back together it's like this
it's like it never stopped it when need
be we're still pretty tight
[Music]